yes hello everyone welcome to today's
live broadcast quantitative
determination of reaction stoichiometry
interaction energies and solute mass is
using analytical ultracentrifugation i
am dr. chad schwartz senior application
scientist at beckman coulter and i'll be
your moderator for today's event we were
delighted to bring you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by beckman coulter beckman
coulter is a leader and centrifugation
and flow cytometry and has long been an
innovator and particle characterization
lab automation and genomics section
culture products are used at the
forefront of important areas of
investigation and discovery for more
information please visit beckman coulter
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is on to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you're going to large the slide
window by clicking on the icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem to the
green Q&A button I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. John
Bergner dr. Bergner has over 50 years of
experience with analytical
ultracentrifugation first using its
spinco model e in 1963 in a laboratory
of frank guard at in Indiana University
Medical School dr. Berger then earned a
PhD at Purdue University for studies on
their reaction mechanisms of lactate
dehydrogenase where he remained as
faculty until retiring in 2009 in
retirement he volunteers his help to the
file physics department at the Virginia
Commonwealth University Medical School
now serving as an adjunct faculty member
with such extensive hands-on training
and experience on analytical
ultracentrifugation dr. Bergner over the
years has taught courses at the nih
and University College of London on
Peter shook said fit and currently
co-teachers Beckman cultures proteome
lab customer training course offered
here in Indianapolis before we get
started I would like to ask the audience
a few poll questions let the pull
populate here the first question is do
you have an analytical ultracentrifuge
in your lab today simple yes or no
question will let the answers populate
and we'll get right back to you
alright pulling up the answers now looks
like 6040 split sixty percent of you are
saying no and forty percent are at yes
our next question and final question
will populate here shortly for which
applications do you use or would you use
your analytical ultracentrifuge multiple
answers are allowed here molecular
weight heterogeneity molecular
aggregation interacting systems
molecular conformation stoichiometry or
other there's a wide variety of
applications out there select the ones
that you use the most just a few more
seconds
looks like the majority are using it for
heterogeneity or molecular aggregation
see that a lot in bio pharma industry
molecular weight comes in at second
twenty-two percent alekhya ler
confirmation 16.2 percent stoichiometry
and interacting systems tied at 14 point
three percent and six point seven
percent use it for other varying
applications so that's the extent of our
full questions I thank everyone for your
answers and I now like to turn it over
to dr. Bergner for his presentation good
morning everyone this is John Bergner
speaky and I'm talking to you from
Richmond Virginia where I currently live
although for many years as he stated I
lived in west lafayette indiana and was
at purdue university and so what I'm
going to talk to you about today is a
number of things all of which relate to
experiments that I have done over the
past few years using the either an XL I
or an XL a analytical
ultracentrifugation wealth University
where I currently serve as an adjunct
professor so anyway what we're going to
talk about is you see in the first slide
or active applications which are
commonly used for the for the yep
analytical since you John would say a UC
from now on but it's easier to say a
measuring solution mass or molecular
mass of the particle the heterogeneity
the number of different types of
particles that you have in a in a
solution and Confirmation and
ate all of America it somehow got turned
around but if that's not a particularly
important use of the auc in terms of
measuring shape stokke ama tree where
were for instance have a heterogeneous
complex and we want to know what x and y
are for something it could be a to be
too for instance the largest still kiama
tree that I've actually ever measured
was a system which you'll hear about
today where we had 240 proteins in the
complex and 240 eligos of DNA and then
finally association constants of the
type to a going to a two or a plus plus
be going to a B and trying to determine
an accurate estimate of what the
dissociation constant is or a two or a B
and one can go much more complex
molecules as well the other nice thing
one can do for instance using peter
shook software is that you can actually
do ITC measurements you can do a light
scattering measurements ultracentrifuge
eeks since the experiments and combine
them in a global fit to to get the
largest or best answer that you can get
the kinds of samples that I've worked
with over the years or course or
proteins nucleic acid polysaccharides
just a little bit they're hard to do
small molecules the smallest molecule
believe it or not is that was air and
that was based on a something that David
you Faunus did many years ago and I
thought maybe I can do that too so we
actually
mejor de an equilibrium sedimentation
for air and then viruses and organelles
and as well as nanoparticles go to the
next slide here so the question that
I've often asked students or postdocs
when they come into lab is what do you
want to know and how much protein do you
have or how much sample do you have and
both of those are important questions
the size and amount and the slide is
laid out a series of questions
difficulty as to whether the experiment
that that they're proposing is easy or
hard and how much sample they would need
they would need size and the amount of a
component often can be a single
experiment that may take six hours to do
or four hours to do doesn't take much
sample we're talking milligram or less
still geometry of a single component is
it a 2 p 2 back that gets a little more
complex and may take a little bit more
protein is a reaction reversible well if
you change the concentration of the
youth slowly and the sedimentation
coefficient that you're measuring from a
velocity experiment again four to six
hours will change and that's indicative
of a reversible process stoichiometric
and energetics of self-association now
we're starting to get more difficult and
we may have to do a number of different
experiments to get get some into some
information about still commentary and
energetics and then finally still
geometry and energetics of hetero
Association that's even more complex
takes more sample now we're talking 10
20 30 milligrams of protein for instance
and and you have to collect more data
which necessarily makes it some more
difficult
okay so uh and now one of the things
that I thought it was important to point
out to people is you know with with the
ex LA and xli you can actually measure
make measurements from about 230
nanometers up to somewhere about around
600 nanometers and I've got a picture of
of the spectrum of BSA there and the two
black arrows indicate the regions where
I typically will look at the wavelengths
that I will normally use in an
experiment either the 280 band or the
valley at 250 now if for instance is
we'll see later on if you happen to use
a sample which has a for instance green
fluorescent protein attached to it then
you can operate it at 290 or 393
nanometers and you don't have conflicts
with if you happen to have a nucleic
acid present or protein you're just
looking at the molecule that you want to
detect and the same way is that if you
have to have a flourishing molecule then
you can operate f around for 90 and be
well away from protein spectra and
nucleic acid spectrum okay so we have a
number of different tools that we can
use just from the from the spectral
information from the sample that you're
using so the first thing I'm going to
talk about and I'm going to back and say
well L needed a absorbance run here will
actually I did interference and
absorbance and this just shows a
sedimentation velocity
experiment where we have and let me
start the whiteboard here and we have a
series of boundaries across here that go
for instance from from left to right and
those are as a function of time and
radio position so each each boundary is
at a given time which i think i remember
right these were 10 minutes apart and
then as you move down there the sample
is moving towards the bottom of the cell
we can analyze that data using the lamb
equation and using the cs distribution
distribution function of said sit and
calculate what's present and we will get
to that in a moment but that's just one
type of experiment this is clearly a
velocity experiment in the next slide I
show a sedimentation equilibrium
experiment with a small 12 kilo dalton
protein and what you see is starting at
the at the top the first scan up here is
that the that's at time 0 and then at
the last scan here at the very top is at
time infinity so to speak and so at that
point you'll notice that the the scans
are getting closer and closer together
and so one is approaching equilibrium
now the interesting thing about this is
is if one is not limited to just doing a
sedimentation equilibrium experiment or
sedimentation equilibrium analysis one
can actually use this all of this data
here and treat it as a velocity
experiment and calculate the mass and
this was this this protein was about
twelve hundred and eighty killer
Dalton's and when we did it and we did
this couple three times is that we got
within a hundred Dalton's of the
sequence mass for the protein so it can
be an accurate way of doing things it's
a lousy way of measuring the
sedimentation proficient because just
the the nature of the curves don't give
you much information about how fast it
said emoni so anyway so the and this is
this is all I'm going to talk about
about the mathematics behind that the
sedimentation and the principal equation
is the lamb equation which is the
differential equation which is a
function of the diffusion coefficient
which is what I'm doing here diffusion
coefficient here and also a
sedimentation coefficient here plus
Omega squared angular acceleration and
radial position R and concentration and
programs like set fit and ultra scan and
the dcd plus will make use of this in
calculating sedimentation coefficients
once you know the sedimentation
coefficient s alright which in the sled
burger equation and also the and the
diffusion coefficient in the said burgh
equation then with with the knowledge of
the buoyancy factor 1 minus V Bar row
then we can calculate these mo
you a mass of the particle uh for
sedimentation equilibrium beta we fit
the data as an exponential and eat there
will be an exponential term for each
salute that's present in the sample and
what we're going to calculate is the the
mass of the particle once we managed to
put in all the so called fudge factors
like the omega squared and the gas
constant and temperature and so forth
okay so going back to the scentee
sedimentation that BSA which i want to
talk about a little bit because it it
shows it in a way it shows the beauty of
the instrument and how accurate it is
and maybe a little bit about some some
prior or a problem that one has to be
aware of although it's not a very big
problem so as I said earlier and I guess
I my guests of 10 minutes was correct
that we have a series of interference
scans hear that so this would be the
distance not the first scan but this is
loosely 30 minutes into the run and then
this would be the second one here would
be 10 minutes later and so forth and now
we're looking down in in this direction
this axis this is radial position here
so and now we fit this using the what's
called a CS distribution which is a
distribution of molecules with a given s
value so what we have here is a large
peak which is at them around 4.3 ass and
then there's two little Peaks one here
and one here and
it's clear well it's well known when the
sequence is known and so forth that BSA
has a molecular weight as I think 68,000
something like that if we analyze this
data and determine molecular weight it
comes out to be a 68,000 so this is the
monomer so what are these two well this
turns out to be a dimer and a trimer and
one of the ways you can almost quickly
tell that this to say this is dimer or
at least give yourself an indication
that it's a dimer is if you take 4.3 and
multiply it by the factor 1.5 then it's
going to be somewhere about six and what
that is saying is that if you take a
sphere of mass one and a sphere of mass
to the s values are going to be related
by to the two-thirds power or about 1.5
nine so and then you can do the same
thing going from here to here doing that
except it would be at the two-thirds
power of three which is 1.7 or something
like that okay so this is that is
something that we're going to look at it
a little bit more in just a second and
this is the experiment conditions we had
we point 1 molar sodium chloride 10
milli molar triste pH 74 and BSA was
about 1.2 big spur bill this is a very
handy test for your centrifuge we use
this quite frequently and just to make
sure that everything is working well but
because we know exactly how the protein
should behave this now is showing a
comparison of three cells for this
particular experiment uh I made up a
batch of sample that in such that I
could
l three different cells with exactly the
same sample and under the same
conditions and then ran them all at the
same time and this peak right here again
is a monomer and you can see for all
three samples that the peaks essentially
overlay one another if you look here at
the dimer peak that's not quite true and
I guess I should put an arrow this is
again the dimer key now if we go down
here this is a blow-up of the 4.3 a
steek and you can see that they don't
overlap quite perfectly and if we go and
look at the UH at the dimer peak again
they don't overlap perfectly and what I
was able to show and also for the trimer
for that matter what I was able to show
was that that this peak we're by doing
several other experiments that this peak
here that is different from the other
two actually is a function of the cell I
we never could quite figure out what the
difference was between the the
centerpiece for for that caused this
problem but it but the experiment
tracked or this peak tracked a
particular centerpiece and the other two
were always gave Peaks that overlapped
so and you just cannot see a difference
between the two feet okay we did this
excuse me we did the same experiment
using the absorbent optics and uh we
again get a peek
here for the the monomer the mana
monomer and then a dimer peak here and
in a trimer peak and maybe it's
detecting some other Peaks out here if
we go look at the next thing what the
next slide I have a comparison here
between the BSA monomer from the
interference data here and then the
absorbance data here and the s values
for these things are the same ok
unfortunately there are different scales
oversight on my part if we go up and
look at the aggregate BSA aggregates all
right this is the interference data and
again we see that one Pete doesn't
overlay the other two and with the
absorbance data the it does over overlap
much better and the reason for that is
that instead of taking 20 milliseconds
to collect a scan for interference data
it takes about 50 seconds of scanned
time to to collect the scan for that and
so the sample during this period of time
is moving and that tends to smear things
out I lower broaden the peak as the time
goes on ok so the lesson there is that
you can get you can get high quality
data it's reproducible and that
occasionally you will end up with a cell
that doesn't behave quite our
centerpiece that doesn't date quite like
the rest okay alright so going on now to
what I was originally going to talk
about is a series of experiments Louth
that I have done here at VCU and this is
on the adeno-associated virus rep 68
protein it's a 61 killer doll
helicase that formstack brings of high
concentration so what I have here is a
series of the experiments at different
concentrations of the helicase so going
from the lowest concentration here where
we have and this is mostly because of
resolution a mixture of monomer and
dimer here and then we have a peek out
here which appears to be a something
much larger and then if we increase the
concentration we now have a better
resolution because we have better signal
to noise and we have now see the resolve
the monomer and the dimer and then down
here is a very likely a tetramer but it
may not be and then this is the the
large peak which actually turns out to
be a seven membered ring okay and we as
we increase the concentration we get
both the ring and this piece here also
grows a spectrum gets more complex as we
get to even higher concentration and we
now have a new peak out here and then
finally at the highest concentration
that we did we have this new peak out
here which actually we think although we
can we haven't really proved the point
yet is that this is a is very likely a
tetra mer of the peaks here so this is a
ring structure and how do we know it's a
ring structure well we've done the
electron microscopy on it that was
supposed to be right here but didn't get
there for some reason rather and you can
clearly see
77 molecules in the in the structure or
seven subunits let's put it that way
here what I've done is because one of
the things we wanted to do was to get
some idea what the dissociation constant
for each of these molecules are uh what
I did was integrate the area under this
peak which gives me a the amount of
protein that is a monomer and then if I
integrate the area of the second peak
here that gives me the area of a or
gives me the amount of the dimer and
from the ratio of those two I can
estimate because these appear to be
these are not in dynamic equilibrium or
let's put it this way they're not in
fast equilibrium they're on slow
equilibrium on a time scale of the
centrifuge so these Peaks are some are
pretty stable they don't shift with time
or going down the centrifuge so we can
guesstimate now that the dissociation
constants for this but for for the
reaction to goes to one is about 1.5
micromolar and two goes to for 1.8 and
then the final one which is where we
close the ring structure we have this is
that this is going to six but it's
probably not six is about tenfold larger
and if you think about it the what is
happening here is for the last molecule
here this is where we're closing the
ring and instead of one interaction
between a monomer two monomers you now
have
to interactions between the two
molecules that go together to form the
ring which you would normally expect
this interaction to be stronger so that
is this one right here the arrow going
the wrong way okay now the other thing
is is this is this is a helicase and so
it binds DNA and we are looking here at
the one of the hollow ghosts that that
bind two reps 68 and this is the origin
of species from the back to the viral
genome and we what we see is is that as
you increase the concentration of
protein in the presence of the of the
all ago is that you get an increasing
amount of this peak that's about 12 s
right here and the ala go at some point
disappears completely like in this
experiment right here this and we only
have the the complex and finally we have
the complex here as well and this turns
out to be also to have seven molecules
in it uh and we're trying we're trying
to now relate the the concentrations to
get some idea of what dissociation
constants are for these things but we
haven't been we haven't convinced
ourselves yet then we have all right so
um the another experiment again uh this
related to this
in a way is this was a pure rna-binding
to to the bacillus pure our protein
response protein and we got interested
in doing centrifuge work on this
molecule in that because the structure
was done at Purdue by Janet Smith and
it's it's a tetraman well what's unusual
about attachment well the binding site
clearly for the RMA is in the middle
here okay and there's no way that the
are that the the pure are RNA molecule
can actually fit in there so the
question is is what what is going on
here is this dissociation dissociating
to form a dimer or is it uh dissociating
to form a monomer or what well so but it
clearly indicated it can't be attached
and there are other forms of this
protein which actually appear to be a
dimer so we didn't do these the first
thing we did was well the first thing we
did was actually a velocity measurement
and for two different forms of the
enzyme one is his tagged and one of them
is is not his tagged and we wanted to be
able to use his tag because we can get
the protein far more pure and because
since we're using RNA if we have any
ribonuclease around our RMA begins to
disappear with time so anyway so what we
wanted to do in this experiment here is
we wanted to see if we can show that as
you decrease the concentration of the
pure are that we would see a change in
the dissociation constant
or the the calculated mass of the
particle as you decrease the
concentration of the protein and so the
highest was over here and the lowest is
over here and what we found was that
there is no significant difference
between the dissociation constant here
and the dissociation constant at the
highest concentration there all right at
90 kill zones and now actually for the
lowest concentration in the amount of
sample amount of signal is pretty low
there and but the software comes back
and indicates that that this is also
90,000 the issue there is you have to be
very careful in your analysis or it it's
simply diverges to meaningless answers
so okay so it doesn't appear to be is it
appears to be a catchment and from the
velocity data over here again it appears
to be attaching the the dissociation
constant or not the dissociation
constant the the mass of the particle in
both cases is around 90 Killa Dalton's
which is very close to the sequence mass
alright so what did we do well what we
did was we started out with an
experiment where we titrated we used
them the ultracentrifuge is a very fancy
tight remettre and so what we did is we
titrated the pure are RNA with the
protein so in the first experiment here
we have a just pure are okay at point
three micromolar and then we started
adding protein
and the protein concentration with ratio
was make one to one here and one to two
next one and so forth and then finally
to the protein so you can see the
protein is with an s value of five and
it shifts in the presence and this is
and this is pure protein right here
ok-ish and it's F value shifts in the
presence of the pure are the so what we
did is that we integrated the peaks and
showed that that the concentration of
free RNA as of as a function of the
ratio of free RNA to to the protein
right here you get a typical titration
curve like lined and that if we use our
imagination and there were to draw the
line across like this then it's going to
give a stoichiometry about two we also
went back and looked at the dissociate
or the masses of these particles and it
appears to be the the ratio of two to
one protein subunits to two RNA particle
now you might say well why did you go to
such extremes to do this because if you
think about it you've got two different
species in here you've got you got
protein which you can measure and and
you've got DNA which or RNA which you
can measure
based on absorbent optics why can't I
just calculate that well the problem
when you're working with RNA or DNA or
RNA Ali goes with proteins is that the
the if the ollie goes have any size to
them that they're absorbent simply
swamps out the protein absorbance and so
you can't you have a difficult time
analyzing the absorbance part the
interference parts easy because it's
just a total mass so anyway we concluded
that it was that this is to on the basis
of two or three observations and that
the affinity based on doing gel shift
assays of the RNA to protein is this in
the 10 10 to 15 nana molar region which
is beyond what we can actually detect
innocent in the AUC okay alright so the
next thing that I want to discuss is a
set of experiments that we did with
Simba's virus and the virus is a large
structure to about 700 nanometers across
here it consists of a core of our ma
there's a single-stranded RNA it has a
capsule around it that's made out of
individual 240 individual capsid
proteins which you probably and then it
has a a lipid membrane which is the blue
region right here and that it it picks
up from the it actually picks this up
from the host as it's being excreted and
then it has a glycoprotein outer layer
which consists of e1 and e2 so um and
what we had two questions we wanted well
the initial question is we wanted to
know something
about this core particle because we can
we can assemble this particle in vitro
very easily with a 48 base pair all ago
and a mixture of the protein and get a
what appears in the electron microscope
is as a sphere and if the homogeneous
particles will see in the hell's a
centrifuge and then one of the things
you sort of can see here at the bottom
is that there is a bridge from the outer
oops wrong way John from the outer
protein to the capsid protein and it's
thought that this is important for and
this this thought this comes from
mutation experiments that this that this
bridge across here is important for
assembly of the outer core of the virus
so what I did was we did a velocity
study alright this is the interference
optics at the top you can see it's a
nice boundary that moves down the cell
it's a little broad which indicates that
there's more than one species present we
also labeled the there lots of the
experiments like this we also then have
a set of experiments where we labeled
the DNA with forcing and then follow the
sedimentation and absorbent objects of
the floor see down the cell but why did
he do that we wanted to find out how
many molecules of DNA how many molecules
of allah Goomer are bound for molecule
of of capsid protein the virologist
wanted to know this piece of information
and this is how we came up with doing it
and so what we did is we calculated we
determine the total mass
from the loading concentration in
fringes for the for the particle and
that is the red line here alright and
then we also have estimated the the
concentration of dial ago which is the
green line here based on the absorbance
of the sourcing derivative and then when
you do Callie do the calculation you
find it that the concentration of acid
protein to DNA is approximately one I
think it came out point ninety so but
that again is 240 copies of the capsid
protein and 240 copies of the of the DNA
now we used a single-stranded DNA here
because it's more stable than the than
the RNA which is the RNA virus it
because this is an are single stranded
RNA virus the other thing that we wanted
to do was to to look at the the thing
that's the the peptide or that is going
through the membrane okay and making
contact with the capsid protein uh and
that and that protein is controversial
whether it exists i mean the the basis
for it is mainly electron microscopy i
the i will say that if you mutate that
you don't get virus you don't get
complete assembled virus so we did two
experiments one we did a a book what we
did to velocity experiments one we did
with the capsid protein in the absence
of RNA and that's the top experiment and
go away
up here and the so what you have here is
this is the RNA no sorry that is the
protein this is the RNA and then this is
a sorry this is the green this you have
green fluorescent protein in here and
that is the one here and over here we
have the capsid protein and the green
fluorescent protein has the e2 peptide
transmembrane need to peptide bound to
it we mix them together we put it in the
centrifuge and we get a new P here which
is a mixture then can be shown based on
the mass the calculated mass is a
mixture then of the capsid protein plus
the the transmembrane eq peptide labeled
with gfp so clearly under the right
conditions you can get a complex between
these two species if you don't have the
e2 or the e2 peptide onto the gfp you
don't get a complex so that was the
control that we did the other thing that
we did was we did a velocity experiment
all right here with the with the core
protein that would be just the the DNA
or the single-stranded DNA plus the
capsid protein and you get a peek uh and
the two peaks one which would be the
fluorescent or the green fluorescent
protein peak and uh and then just a
second here I'm saying that wrong yeah
okay with it with the green fluorescent
protein and with a peptide label to it
and there is some fluorescence here uh
but we're not convinced that it is real
and it may only be a just one or two
molecules of the the peptide bound to it
so this experiment here is not too
informative as we have actually we're
not working with it anymore but it it
was not as conclusive as we would like
to have seen but the one at the top is
clearly shows that the the protea the
peptide gfp complex will bind to the
capsid protein all right so um this is
another experiment where were actually
measured a small protein and we did a
sanitation velocity at which is shown by
the experiment over here and this is the
distribution down here the cs
distribution so again that's the
distribution of molecules with a
different size or different s value and
now what i've done on this side and this
is is that i have done this experiment
at three different concentrations and
you can see that the that you begin to
develop a peek here at two and a higher
s value which would seem to be the dimer
and so what you can do is you can
integrate these peaks so you integrate
the entire peak okay and you can put
this into peter shook software as an
isotherm for us and do a calculation and
uh and what
you're going to fit is you're going to
fit an seiu for the well typically what
we fit is simply the KD because we know
what s and so forth is for the this
molecule for the monomer and and then do
a fit and you can see here that the
calculator the data for the different
isotherms over here the different
isotherms here for a different
concentrations can be fit nicely with a
model where you have a monomer dimer
equilibrium that is is slow and by slow
on the time scale of the centrifuge and
so we're plotting fw isotherm over here
versus the concentration of the protein
the fit looks very nice and we get a KD
of about 270 micromolar well the
importance of this was simply to show
well lovely stated this way uh the
structure of this molecule had been done
at Virginia Commonwealth and but it
clearly looked like that the protein was
a dimer but the contact area between the
two monomers was not all that great and
so that's always a problem the
crystallographers come up with is this
contact meaningful or not meaningful
from the biological sense so we got a
dissociation constant for this of 270
micromolar and the conclusion was is
this probably is not meaningful but we
don't really know it's sort of in the
iffy stage for state as far as that this
protein actually is a secreted by a
bacteria that lives in your gum lines
and it acts to inhibit immune responses
against the bacteria I thought it was
really clever of the bacteria and then
the final thing here is that well I'm
not going to talk much about this this
is again with the the the experiment we
talked about earlier with the
equilibrium day day you can go ahead and
fit the data and as I said it comes out
indicating that it is a 90 kilo dalton
tettemer so the final thing that I was
going to talk about is a velocity
experiment and in the top experiment
here we have a weekend we have velocity
data for a protein at some concentration
and what I did is fit this using said
fat and determine the cs distribution
plot for it so now we have two clearly
two species here one which is a monomer
and the other is a dimer and so the
question is is can we estimate a
dissociation constant for this molecule
and you when you try to do this and this
is we're now switching instead of using
fitting individual CS distributions
we're now fitting it in terms of a model
system of a plus a goes to a to other
words mom or dimer equilibrium so what
we've information that we have to put in
here is to lock it away to the monomer
the molecular weight of the or the s
value for the monomer which we can get
here and we can later calculate and then
we're to calculate a KD for this
molecule which is here and then we're
going to
calculate a less value for the dimer and
so if you fit the data this way then you
get numbers which in this case endure
this experiment and not very good
because the data seems to have some
problems I did some additional things
with the data but could never get a
really great fit for this data the one
conclusion which I could have made up
here on the basis of this data is that
the dissociation constant which is 3.4
is again in the hundred-plus that
nanometer not ma'am you 100 + michael
polar region so it's not a very strong
association so that is pretty much what
we intend I intended to tell you today
and show you that that the kind of
experiments that one can do and the kind
of optical measurements that one can
make that make in some cases back of the
end of envelope calculations possible
we're using the AUC and the various
samples so if people have questions I
will be happy to answer them in the
remaining three minutes and 14 seconds
but thank you for that data bergna that
was a great presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
that you can submit questions by typing
them in the Q&A box at the lower left of
the presentation window we've had
several that's already came in our first
question is whether or not there is a
limit in the mass of the sedimentation
coefficient that you can analyze by a UC
yes there is uh at the inn there's
really two different limits it depends
if you're
working with a velocity system I'm sorry
not velocities if you're working with
absorbance then the the limit is
somewhat smaller than it is with
interference because you can make the
measurement faster with interference and
you can with absorbance you can collect
sufficient data to get an answer the the
the answer is in terms of size and I'm
going to give this to you in terms of
sedimentation coefficient is about
25,000 s that that one can measure now
when you have 25,000 nast you probably
are not going to get more than two or
three scans from the instrument and you
probably won't see a single scan with
the absorbance so the this it's more a
how fast to sample sediments as opposed
to actually the size of the settlement
if the if for instance you have a
polystyrene bead which has a density
very close to water then you can have
much larger particles in there then if
you happen to have a gold particle which
has a molecular weight of whatever gold
has but is dependent upon the size and
they will set them look very rapidly and
so there's a limit how big the gold
particles can be then answer the
question you think yes definitely thank
you our next question there was a few
questions that came in of sedimentation
equilibrium versus velocity when would
you use one type of experiment versus
the next ok I'm going to give you a
smart aleck answer ok I personally would
just assume never use sedimentation
equilibria I like sedimentation blocked
me and I will explain what one is that i
oftentimes can
get an answer on a problem in three or
four hours with by sedimentation
velocity and it may take a week by
sedimentation equilibrium I mean if
you're looking at a large protein for
instance the the experiment that i
showed you using the pier our protein
which was 90,000 Dalton's each one of
those lines each one of those scans took
40 hours to come to equilibrium so that
experiment I could have been maybe
there's an advantage of doing this that
experiment I could have set it up picked
my speeds put those in the centrifuge
and gone home for a week and then come
back later oh and go on fishing that
sounds like a good use of your time our
next question is whether or not an alga
mer which forms a soluble aggregate and
comes out in the void volume and jill
gel filtration it cannot be determined
by a you see I don't have a good feeling
for how large the of an oligomer won't
come out in the void volume but my guess
is that and I will say this that we have
done a few experiments with exosomes
which are fairly large particles and
managed to to get useful information
we've also done viruses which and gotten
useful information so in these are large
particles millions molecular weight so
my guess is in my approach to this is
always going to be it only cost me a day
or less to actually measure this or to
actually run an experiment to find out
whether i can get useful information and
you can always if you don't
may you see you can always find somebody
will do it for you yeah thank you thank
you again dr. Berger unfortunately we
are out of time I want to thank the
audience for the interesting questions
and participation in today's event I
would also like to thank our sponsor
beckman coulter and of course dr. John
Bergner for making today's educational
webcast possible which will also be
available for on-demand viewing through
beckman coulter com thanks again goodbye